welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and loki episode one has arrived
bringing with it a freaking glossary of
new marvel terms and insane easter eggs
but just as many if not more details are
hidden in the end credit sequence of
every episode
and looking closely at these might clue
us in even more about what this series
is really all about so i'm gonna comb
through these end credits frame by frame
to explain what all this stuff means
we begin with loki's case file his
thumbprints that the tba used to match
loki to his crimes but underneath it is
a report referring to loki's plea
agreement it looks like it's a bit hard
to make out but it seems to reference
him pleading guilty to count
two but not to all of it maybe since
loki admitted guilt to being the god of
mischief and finding this all tedious
but not to violating the sacred timeline
yeah it's a bit weird for
names to be redacted though since the
tba seems like a secret organization
even loki didn't know about
so what public scrutiny would they have
to worry about
unless some higher reps of the tva are
keeping secrets from their own ranks
it's a total conspiracy
total conspiracy directed by kate herron
appears over a coffee pot labeled fresh
800 bc maybe a nod to heron's coffee
drinking
but also a joke about how the tva
apparently drinks discontinued beverages
from the past
like justa and boku coffee wasn't
reportedly drank until like the 15th
century but who knows maybe it was
way older and just forgotten from
history when we see another tva poster
hunters and analysts working in tandem
a tall female minutemen holding out a
high five to a wormy little analyst
who is low-fiving sacred timeline
dividing them
yeah they look like they hate each other
and clearly do not connect
reflecting how the tva desk workers like
casey don't really get along with hunter
b-15
and that bureaucratic weakness could get
exploited by loki and by others
but before i continue thanks to ray
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
use the links below to download raid to
your mobile phone or your pc
over 76 million people have played raid
that's four times the population of new
york city and proof that there's
something great for everyone what i
really like about the game is the
character design the artists at radar
famous for their attention to detail and
incredible design
like check out iron braggo one of the
strongest orc champions and he looks
like
he's got a chain meal beard and like a
skull shoulder pads
i don't really know who to look at raid
has got a jam-packed schedule of events
this summer and tons of new content
new champions getting released a new
rotation of the doom tower
all kinds of tournaments and events if
you want to get a huge head start in
raid
all you have to do is hit the link in
the description and you'll get an epic
hero tronorou
who's amazing in the doom tower 200 000
silver one xp boost one energy refill
and one ancient shard
so that you could summon an awesome
champion as soon as you get in game
all this stretcher will be waiting for
you here and once you're in you can find
me in game under the name
new rock 2020 and if you're fast you can
join my clan
and it's that easy just click the link
in the description i'll see you in the
game now to the right of that are some
pinned equations and figures you
actually get clear shots of this later
in the sequence
figure r shows these variants a stick
figure with nine
duplicates branching off from him
remember that number nine but then
beneath that drawings of wormholes aka
einstein rose and bridges and then
beneath that hold onto your butts
schrodinger's equation so erwin
schrodinger was a theoretical physicist
known for pioneering quantum mechanics
and the many worlds theory
disputing einstein's explanation of
newtonian physics he really was all
about trying to quantify what he called
the wave form of subatomic particles
ultimately positing that bodies can
exist
simultaneously in multiple parallel
realities
you might know his thought experiment
schrodinger's cat in which schrodinger
suggested that if he were to put his cat
in a closed box
with two dishes of food one of them
poisoned while that lid stays closed and
he can't observe the cat that cat
is both simultaneously alive and dead
in two parallel reality states now
marvel studios is clearly well versed in
these concepts
eric selvig's chalkboard and thor the
dark world reference jody nurse cat
ant-man and the wasp the movie that
mocked quantum everything and set up
kang the conqueror's home city of
chronopolis in the quantum realm
also discussed this idea from bill
foster the object in question would be
both in and out of phase
with multiple parallel realities and an
avengers end game built on this
consulting experts in quantum mechanics
to produce its explanation of branch
realities which is how we got dialogue
like
tony after everything you've seen is
anything really quantum fluctuation
messes with a plank scale which then
triggers the deutsche proposition can we
agree on that
and now loki is building on endgame's
timeline logic with loki's escape from
the time heists creating a branch
timeline
that captain america never restored
making loki a variant on the tv8 [ __ ]
list and by the way after episode 1
if that background variant was peggy
carter maybe even cap's decision to stay
in the past with peggy created another
nexus violation a branch timeline
that the tpa plans to prune but anyway
back to this credit sequence nearby
those equations
is a figure showing overlapping and
concentric circles
around nine of them at least including
that donut at the top and another circle
inside it
with a line pointing directly to the
center labeled tva
possibly showing us the location of the
tva in between
the nine realms and then to the far left
a tva archive
apocalyptic event report under event
details
failure to intervene in dire
circumstances and then beneath that
fri capital f maybe friday or the person
that day of the week is based on
the norse figure of friega so this could
be a report about loki's failure to
intervene
in the dark elves attack on asgard later
in the sequence another apocalyptic
event report describes loki's hijacking
of the seattle flight
as db cooper in 1971 which we saw in the
episode
so the tva considers each of these
apocalyptic events
which maybe could connect these kind of
reports to loki's upcoming interference
with the destruction of pompeii which
was truly apocalyptic
to those people exec producer stephen
broussard shows up over
a thick reference book underneath that
book is another apocalyptic event report
based on the formatting of it and then
notice there's a tab in this reference
book that opens up to
atlas so maybe someone is researching
past apocalyptic events
in world history like pompeii exec
producer kate herron over some light up
switches on a chrono monitor board
each button labeled with these three
character codes which maybe correspond
to the buttons on the tva
elevator especially since the orange one
at the bottom of that board
appears to show miss minutes as we have
an elevator button for miss minutes
go exec producer kevin r wright over
this diagram of this variant
branching down into five variant figures
his circle head toggling into a square
triangle pentagon hexagon and x we
actually see these guys again later this
is probably some textbook or some
handbook
explaining the whole variant process and
the number of these guys does parallel
the yellow bow tied man in miss minutes
cartoon
who also spawn the same number of
variants so another page shows a figure
running through a portal with the words
effects on the left and then you can
make out the words a strip of paper
giving it
then the ends back together then draw a
line along the center
and then runs along both yeah maybe this
is explaining how the tva portals
through time
with the strip of paper bending and its
ends time back together essentially
describing a mobius strip
which tony stark used to decode time
travel back in endgame
you see line producer trish standard
over kablooey gum flavor blueberry this
is all in a tva evidence bag so yeah
that temporal aura analysis mobia
ordered
will probably end up yielding something
then edited by paul zucker over the tva
holo projector 35 which by the way is
actually a welteron
2004's baseball 8-track stereo from 1971
and we get a close-up of the film strip
because that's how editors used to have
to manually clip and paste film strips
in the days of linear editing my
breakdown has an interesting easter egg
of something written on this film strip
now the upms and assistant directors
show over the elevator buttons and
notice how the screen jumps from tsy
fhf 2we iul and right when it hits 1ej
access denied so some part of the tva
must be off limits and maybe this floor
is for that nightmare department that
mobius mentioned
maybe a tie into the character nightmare
from the doctor strange world
then visual effects producer allison
paul over more tva paperwork where a
mind stone
is actually being used as a paperweight
as casey said many of them do
then eugene cordero's name appears over
one of the tva clocks with suddenly
many alternate colored hands note that
the green one is
longest patiently ticks its way
backwards
maybe like our loki variant patiently
defies the natural flow of time
tara strong's name appears over a binder
for if you look at that label redacted
reports
again not sure why anything would need
to get redacted in an organization
facing zero public scrutiny unless total
conspiracy and then this archive drawer
with number nine
circled now as we saw on the cubicle
wall earlier there's this geometric
shape with numbered corners but the
corner with nine
is circled there there could be a
connection here with the nine realms
maybe nine is the maximum number of
variants one can have
that will just be the magic number we
look for in loki now on mobius desk is
wake
magazine looks like a jet ski in water
sports magazine
and if you look closely offers a free
poster inside hello
and then we end on the faces of the
timekeepers that we saw in the courtroom
and we specifically punch in on the
middle one now compared to the other two
faces
mustachy being the timekeeper xanthe and
stalk eyebrows being bored
that leaves this middle one as asked but
here maybe it's a perspective thing but
doesn't asks right eye look like it's
drooping down
like right before we cut to black now i
know i've compared ask's appearance here
in the courtroom to the face of jonathan
majors playing kang the conqueror in
quantomania
a character romantically linked with
justice rent slayer framed right in this
figure's lips
but i'm just saying by closing the
credits on this stroke-suffering
timekeeper clearly the show wants
us to keep a less droopy eye on them so
support this channel by checking out our
new
loki inspired merch options like the
shirt loki out of time looks so great
can't wait to get mine
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
breakdowns of everything loki thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you